The Joe Rogan experience?
No.
Zero.
I don't know anything about coding,
but do you have like is there a spell check for coding?
Yeah.
So it's kind of called debugging is trying to find bugs and it's a software
that's doing this.
Yeah.
Software.
So there's,
depending on the programming language and everybody should,
uh,
if you,
if you haven't tried programming,
you should try it.
It's cool.
It's the future should learn to program.
Okay.
That's my plug.
These supposed to learn to code.
You can get started.
What did that at [inaudible] apartment?
Scared of it.
I,
it's a problematic term.
I don't actually know why it's the dumbest fucking problematic code of all time
because someone ridiculously was suggesting that coal miners could maybe learn
how to code computer code and like get a different job.
They can be trained.
And so as someone,
the way people were looking at it like that,
that was a,
uh,
like a frivolous suggestion and that it was ridiculous to try to get someone who
is 50 years old.
It doesn't have any education in computers at all to change their job from being
a coal miner to learning how to code.
So they started saying it to politicians and people mocking it,
but then what Twitter alleged was that what was going on was it was being
connected to white supremacy and antisemitism and a bunch of different things.
Like people were saying,
learn to code,
and they were putting in a bunch of these other phrases in my suggestion would
be,
well that's a different fucking thing.
Like now you have like you look,
you have a problem with Nazis and white supremacists,
but that's the promise with Nazis and white supremacists when someone is just
saying,
learn to code,
mocking this ridiculous idea that you're going to teach,
you know,
that's a,
that's a legitimate criticism of someone's perspective that you're going to get
a coal miner to learn how to fucking do computer coding.
It's crazy.
It's so people getting banned for that.
Rightly so.
People were furious.
The Way Google described to me and Tim Pool and we were discussing it,
was that Google,
I mean,
excuse me,
Twitter,
the way Twitter described it was that essentially we're dealing with something
where they were trying to censor things at scale.
There was,
there was so many people and there's so much going on that it's very difficult
to get it right and that they've made mistakes.
I think that's a fast,
one of the most fascinating applications of AI actually is filtering,
trying to manage pewter learning.
[inaudible] so using machine learning to manage this huge conversation.
You're talking about 500,
I believe it's 500 million tweets a day,
something like that.
And he,
Jamie makes at least three,
three 91
I was going to say with this conversation,
I saw this recently,
I don't know who did the data on this,
but there's a,
uh,
a statement someone put on Twitter that said that of,
um,
let me see if I can word it correctly.
It was 22% of adult Americans
are on Twitter.
Whoa.
All right.
So that's like,
that's like a fact,
one of that 10% make up 80% of the tweets created by adult Americans.
2% of the people on Twitter make up 80% of the tweets.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
A lot of people arguing aggressively and the,
and the question of how to manage that and you can't manage that,
but just a manual,
a review of [inaudible]
yeah.
You'd have to have so many employees.
Yeah.
That's I think more likely.
I don't think Jack is lying,
but um,
nor is Vigia but I do think that they have a clear bias against conservatives
and that's being shown.
So that's an interesting question.
I have a your friend,
my friend and mentor,
Eric Weinstein.
Yes.
Talk to me.
I disagreed with him a little bit on this.
I think,
uh,
he basically believes so there's a bias.
It boils down to the conversation that Jack is having at the,
at the top level,
inside Twitter.
What,
what is that conversation like?
Uh,
I think,
I tend to believe,
again,
this might be my naive nature is that they have,
they don't have bias and they have just,
they're trying to manage this huge flood of,
um,
of tweets and what they're trying to do is not buy,
is not to remove sort of conservative as the liberals and so on.
They're trying to,
uh,
remove people that lead to,
others leaving the conversation.
So they want more people to be in the conversation.
I think
that's true as well,
but I think they definitely are biased against conservative people.
There was a,
an Alexander x,
Alexandra AOC.
Octavia,
how's it?
AOC is good.
Cortez is the last one.
Is it Octavia?
Ocasio that's right.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Alexandra AOC.
Sorry,
I'm just,
I'm thinking I was,
there wasn't planning on talking about her,
but,
um,
there was a parody account and someone was running his parody account,
which was very mild,
just humorous parody account.
They were banned permanently for running it and then their own account was
banned as well.
Whereas,
um,
you know,
there's some progressive people are liberal people that post all sorts of crazy
shit.
And they don't,
they don't get banned at the same brain.
It's really clear that someone in the company,
whether it's up for manual review,
whether it's at the discretion of the people that are employees,
when you're thinking about a company that's a silicone valley company,
you are in without doubt.
You're dealing with people that are leaning left.
There's so many that lean left in silicon valley.
The idea that that company was secretly run by Republicans is ridiculous.
They're,
they're almost all run by Democrats or progressive people.
So that the leadership level,
there's,
there's a narrow mindedness that,
that,
that permeates all silicon valley saying.
Well,
the question,
I think there's a leaning left that permeate silicone valley.
I think that's undeniable.
I think it's undeniable.
I mean,
I think if you had a poll,
the people that work in silicone valley where their political leanings are,
I think it would be by far left.
I think it would be the vast majority.
Um,
does that mean that affects their decisions?
Well,
what's the evidence?
it's kind of shows us does,
you know,
it's,
they're not treating it with 100% clarity and you know,
across the board accuracy or,
um,
fairness rather.
I think that there's absolutely people that work there that lean and there's
been videos where they've captured people,
uh,
that were Twitter employees talking about it,
talking about how you do that,
how you,
uh,
make their,
you know,
fuck you find someone who's a using Trump talk or,
saying sad at the end of things and someone's talking,
he's gonna,
you know,
that certain characteristics they look for and there's been videos of what does
that project Veritas with that guy,
uh,
got his employees got undercover footage of Twitter employees talking about that
kind of stuff.
The question is how much power do those individuals have?
How many individuals are there like that I are that are those people
exaggerating their ability and what they do at work or they,
are they talking about something that used to go on but doesn't go on anymore?
I don't know.
I don't work there.
I think it boils down to I,
I'm one of those people that believes it's bows out to the leadership and people
at the top set the culture and the culture has to be,
it cannot be this kind of silicon valley narrow minded,
uh,
sort of left leaning thinking even if you believe even if you're a hardcore
liberal,
you cannot,
when you operate the car,
when you drive and manage a conversation in the entire world,
you have to think about Middle America.
You have to think about,
you have to have fundamental respect for human beings who voted for Trump.
It is a concerning thing for me to see just a narrow mindedness of an all forms.
One of the reasons I enjoy listening to this podcast is you're pretty open
minded.
That open mindedness is essential for leaders of Facebook and Twitter.
People who are managing conversations.
I think so too.
I think it's,
I think it's a s the thought of being open minded and acting in that ethic is
probably one of the most important things that we could go forward with right
now because things are getting so greasy.
It's so slippery on,
on both sides.
And we're in this weird position that I don't recall ever in my life there being
such a divide between the right and the left in this country.
I know it's more,
more vicious,
more angry,
more hateful.
It's different than at any other time in my life.
And I think a lot of our ideas are based on these narratives that or may not
even be accurate.
And then we support them and we reinforce them on either side.
We reinforce them on the left,
we reinforce them on the right where if you're looking at reality itself and you
don't have these,
uh,
clear parameters and these clear ideologies,
I think we're way,
most of us are way more in the middle than we think we are.
Most of us are.
We just don't want racist run in the country.
We don't want socialists given all our money away.
We don't want to pay too much in taxes to a shitty government.
We don't want schools getting underfunded.
We,
we all,
you know,
and then we decide what,
what does my team like the team that I,
the shit that I like is that this team,
well,
not everything,
but they've got a lot of things.
So I'll go with them.
Maybe I'm not a religious nut,
but I'm fiscally conservative and I don't like with Democrats like to spend
money.
I'm going to go with the Republicans.
You know,
maybe,
maybe I'm more,
I'm more concerned with the state of the economy and the way we trade with the
world than I am with certain social issues that the Democrats embrace.
So I'll lean that way.
Even though I do support gay rights and I do support this and I do support all
these other progressive ideas this way more of us in that boat.
There's way more of us that are in this middle of the whole thing
for sure.
But there it goes up and down.
So all of us,
so I'm open,
I believe.
I hope I am open minded most of the time.
But you have different moods.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
And the question is,
this is where the role of AI comes in.
Does the AI that recommends what tweets I should see what Facebook messenger
that's just see is that encouraging the darker parts of me or the the Steven
pinker better angels of our nature though cause it,
what stuff is it showing me?
Because if it shows me,
uh,
stuff that if the AI trains purely unclicked,
it may start to learn when I'm in a bad mood and point me to things that might
be upsetting to me.
And so escalating that division and escalating this viral thing that can be
solved most likely with people training a little more Jujitsu or something.
Well it's the size Facebook
algorithm that encourages people to be outraged because accidentally,
not even on purpose,
but this is what engages people.
Well this is what gets clicks.
So they find out,
oh well he clicks on things when he finds out that people are anti vaccination
or he clicks on things when he finds out,
you know what,
it fill in the blank with whatever the subject is.
And then you get these mother fuckers,
you know,
this is the reason why measles is spreading and you start getting an angry,
I mean the anti vaccs arguments on Facebook,
I don't know if you ever dip into those waters for a few minutes and watch
people fight back and forth and in fury and anger,
you know,
it's a,
it's another one of those things that becomes a extremely lucrative,
uh,
subject for any social media empire.
If you're,
if you're all about getting people to engage and that's where the money is in he
to getting people to Click on the page and the ads are on those pages,
you get those clips,
get that money if that's how the system is set up.
And I'm not exactly sure how it is cause I don't really use Facebook,
but that's what it benefits.
I mean that's what,
that's what it gravitates towards.
Gravitates towards controversy.
So,
and when we think about concern for AI systems to talk about sort of terminate
or I'm sure we'll,
we'll touch on it,
but I think of Twitter as a whole,
as one organism.
That is the thing that worries me the most is the artificial intelligence that
is very kind of dumb and simple,
simple algorithms that are driving the behavior of millions of people and at
together the kind of chaos that we can achieve.
I mean,
that algorithm has incredible influence in all society.
Twitter are,
our current president is on Twitter so much.
Oh yeah.
All Day,
all night.
The,
the,
I mean,
it's scary to think about.
We talk about autonomous vehicles leading to fate to l one fatality to
fatalities is scary.
To think about what the difference,
a small change in the f in the Twitter algorithm.
I mean,
I,
it could start wars.
It really could.
And that if you think about the long term,
if you think about is one AI organism that is a super intelligent organism that
will have no control over.
And I think it all boils down honestly,
to the leadership,
to Jack,
uh,
to,
to two and other folks like him making sure that he's open minded.
He goes hunting,
then he goes,
uh,
does some Jujitsu that he eats some meat and sometimes goes Vegan.
Right?